hey Here I am at the corner of Hollywood
and Vine beneful Hollywood California my
grandma was again remember my grandpa
was a gang gang member and I didn't know
better the only way somebody can take
your property is if they steal it am i
right that's why the government invented
eminent domain eminent domain is like
cancer but there's one thing they sell
here in California that's legal that the
federal government doesn't want you to
have you want my gun you better take it
off my dead body I've always been a
Republican if medical marijuana was
decriminalized nationally if the DEA
stood down well that smell the smell of
freedom shut up shut up Pilate declare a
lot more violent a proper what I would
love to own a freeway in LA my average
speed is between nine and 16 miles an
hour hey you ready for the easiest way
to work you ever had in your life hope
the helicopter doesn't crash
the best word to show my funeral oh it
does so that was a blast huh yeah
exactly the reason about TV I'm drew
carey and I'm out of here in a
helicopter
you